[Música]
kiçula
quem nunca escondi minha mãe conheceu
flórida i
[Música]
lembrando que quando eu faço essa
dancinha que eu não ganho pourri o
direitos autorais bancos leva tudo o pai
então clique em gostei pra ganhar alguma
coisa pelo menos lá e por que não
crescer se você não é inscrita no canal
este botão aqui e chama inscrever-se
quem você é um seguidor do canal se não
perde nada tá então clique em
inscrever-se muita gente a assistir os
vídeos não é inscrito no canal e não se
inscreveu e agora e agora vamos ao vivo
porque eu não faço vídeo b do ano
passado
e aí galera que assistiu o campeonato
com vocês e estou aqui na tailândia de
férias provavelmente quando você estiver
assistindo esse vídeo já estou no brasil
já faltando que precisa trabalhar pela
receita no dia nas férias de janeiro no
rio de janeiro na fundição progresso tem
várias opções e pode lá no meu site ou
fazendo turnê mundial também europa
estados unidos e japão têm vários olha
no meu site pode comprar ingressos
online
eu assistir box a todo mundo falando em
conta todo mundo fala que tem que
assistir beleza netflix falar merda né
então os seus belos quadros amélio que a
sandra books o santo andré começou mal
por tabela viu a notícia da televisão o
apresentador boa noite foram todos na
rússia as pessoas estão todas de drogas
e matando no meio da rua e muda de canal
japão a gente não entrar na união de
ontem dando conta de troca também na rua
tv arrumamalaê a ramalá e caiu 2 a 1 vai
se matar
no brasil a doença está tomando de conta
das ruas de joão pessoa na paraíba as
pessoas vendem chip de celular como ela
não essa notícia não as pessoas estão
correndo loucas enfurecidos depois de
ver algo no céu que não existe pois vê
ela tem transtornos psiquiátricos e se
mata no meio da rua e agora vamos para
os esportes ilesa pelas notícias e falar
ela na [ __ ] que pariu vai dar nada não
quem não dá não chega aqui e ela está
grávida só parece cantar muito a fim não
digitar grávida não se falar pai não faz
isso que você está agradando nem fazer o
pré-natal e lama deus tem que fazer pra
natal fazer 13 só a meio da sua seleção
não ia fazendo um traço nela do meu deus
do céu diz que bosta por favor diz que
boston e terminou de fazer tudo que
tinha pra fazer não terminou e lá e
terminou ela vai embora na hora que ela
está indo embora tudo nada a ver uma
mulher fazendo assim no vídeo
aí eu saí correndo com o carro da irmã e
também faço eu fui eu fui ver o tempo
del teúl o que foi van
mulher é aquela doença passa na
televisão acabou de chegar aqui também
meu deus vou estar vendendo chique do
hospital não eram as pessoas estão se
matando em goiânia pela revisão estão
porque também eu desde um carro bate na
frente do carro dela e eu posso cíntia
não sei que é necessário que a pessoa
tenha entrado em um carro toda vez que
um apocalipse todo mundo está vendo um
carro e todo mundo começa aquela [ __ ]
rebateu no zozô porque ninguém faz assim
oh meu deus está aqui no apocalipse
não peguei nem do carro se matar e matar
usou aí meu jogo começa a [ __ ]
acontecer esta explodiu no carro batendo
o carro vendendo chip aí meu amigo a
irmã dela vem a coisa ela não viu que
faltava pega no negócio do banco de trás
na hora sei quando ela virou e poderá
assim já entrou nesse caso pronto vai
bater num carro capota mandaram sair do
carro entra na frente de um caminhão em
cima dela levantando que eu paguei pelo
chão e a [ __ ] rolando amigo por
gritando hoje milhão e o povo é possível
esse material é o chelsea matou mim não
é possível se mata a mulher vai ajudar
ela tá pelo chão grávida a mulher se
mata também antes do acaso que a galera
está preparada a galera tá com a arma e
tudo que ela já sabe a galera pensou sul
deu faz tempo assim que começou há pouco
deu tranco tudo ea janela tudo fechado
porque eles entenderam que tipo assim eu
ver qualquer coisa que venha de fora
você ray davies calypso que a galera usa
banda não entendeu a poder entrar
qualquer coisinha feixes rio já aqui
aonde está a câmera 16 h lera tenta
ligar no celular em nada e nada demais
nada de bluetooth nada de na a uma copa
lippi se total a galera começa a botar
as coisas que viu o rapaz morreu o céu
estava fazendo um suco e se o amoled
buscador obteria o meu chefe que
trabalhar na obra entrou debaixo do
tractor com a portaria meu primo que
trabalhava no site shopping e dizer foi
que ele fez voltar e eu não vivo ou seja
eles chega à conclusão de que se você
ver você quer se matar na hora deu a
ninguém sabe o que é porque quem morre
porque é será que as pessoas vêem será
será que elas vêem assim o que elas mais
tem medo de ver aquelas ver o que mais
dá vontade iria fazer assim uma página
eu acho que eu ia ver meu pai transando
olha deixa o olhar
ai meu deus será que o beijo eu vou
pensar um pouquinho
achei engraçado esse filme que ninguém
arriscou o tiro o som olho à risca só
uma pessoa que fica são lá querem se
matar eo tudo bem vou arriscar
eu vou escalar 11
ai ai ai agora quer uma regra de ouro é
que as pessoas viam o próprio de boxe
que todo mundo que viu que a equipe não
utilizará para mostrar outras pessoas já
haviam me de volta e vi falar no twitter
lá mas não quero assistir não tem que
assistir pitboys só assistir que eu ia
falar de trabalho na próxima semana eu
assisti não você vai assistir agora
assista
vejo um bis de bock seu melhor
sustenta que fosse verdade dá para se
enganar as pessoas não chove o celular
mas só de abril um sol foi embora jamais
substituir muito tempo eu passei o dia
todo ano a rua irmã tá passando onde
dedicou pássaros acesso na loja então
werley
eu ia ser o primeiro a morrer de ciúme
porque as pessoas não podem ver uma
audição delas tem tabu em meu ouvido é
toda roubar eu só escuto música
estourando meus ouvidos a escuta
skrillex do volume sempre tudo tá tudo
pra so sul do velho na primeira
oportunidade morrer pessoa acabou a
comida não morrer de fome acha que
precisa achar um lugar tipo mercadinho
ou uma venda eu quero ir à venda ainda
me viro big brother galera começa poder
não tem mais comida que a gente vai
fazer e chegou a gravar na casa agora
são duas grávidas em tomar conta tem que
ter comida esses vinhos nascer saudável
que é isso que o ser humano tem que
fazer proteger os bebês aí um deles dá
uma brilhante idéia de falar vamos olhar
pelas câmeras de segurança porque a
gente vê coisas em ver diretamente em
tron né
o que acontece moss quebrou o pescoço eo
sangue derramado pelo chão emop começa a
faltar comida de verdade o que a gente
vai fazer
eles entram dentro de um carro campos
vidro do carro e vou olhando pelo gps
até o mercado ele centro todo mundo
dentro do carro
a cometer essa passivo de imensa doença
andré melo quer viver num país que dê
pra ele gps com os olhos fechados até o
ver carlos vou de varzim pela rua
passando devagar sem por cima dos corpos
das pessoas por pouco isso acabou cidade
pode ter quebra mola wilmington é doido
e é lá que ela encontra os passarinhos
entendeu nesse mercado e porque ela
entra no mercado está os passarinhos
alguém bate na porta de passagem fica
agitado fica bem ea pessoa que está
batendo na porta a deixou em traje por
favor me ajude os passarinhos e os
outros vão deixar entrar eu passei na
pacata vai morrer o passarinho alguém a
propósito com a bota a cara que começa
vocês têm que ver vocês têm que vem os
passarinhos o cara pulou do cara caiu do
lado de fora fechar a porta já morreu
dólar produto ou seja os passarinhos
sabem quando coisa muita se aproximando
por isso não do filme hebert boxes e deu
ela lava os passarinhos em da caixa
então são os verdes nos boxes fosse
peixe seria fish boxe porque seria pap
boxe foi um chinês seria china in box
se fosse no brasil cara [ __ ] que ia
ser no rio de janeiro a [ __ ] vianna
júnior tirou a vida de um negócio bolado
manaus - passado embora todos nós vamos
ter que usar uma galinha aninho no piauí
o menininho
olha não bom
a paraíba é um cara aberto elf rapariga
que mais defendeu passarem por um tiro
na cara tinha guerra da banana
passarinha na bahia o velho vou lhe
dizer vou tirar sabendo arquivo agora
você que vai na minha frente e se pega
com força maior ou se pede well see
privacidade beira rio fossati não meto
minha [ __ ] domingo o metrô ea porrada
imagine ao exercício feito diz nada mas
amanhã vai mandar alguém tem uma galinha
o velho ninguém pega leve não vou agora
no mesmo mês passado a promotoria forró
bom momento lá pô eu vou aí eu tiro só
veio o tiro só venda chegava em mim
antes na minha venda a dá lo aí a moça
grávida e deixa um cara entrar porque
deixar ela entrar ela ficou com raiva o
sentimento está lá fora é muito ruim eu
vou deixar para ele ela deixou para
entrar para falar onde pergunta para
saber se ela é boa ele começa a falar
que tem uma galera que parece que não é
afetada por que olhe não morre só acho
bonito que adorar sei lá fazer oq fazer
as outras pessoas vêm também as belezas
da outra senhora lá né américa mec a
principal ea outra moça grávida ea outra
vou jogar até porque ela prometa que a
mesma vai cuidar do filho dessa água com
a acontecer ea meta não quer cuidar
muito dela não vejo ela usou a [ __ ]
duas começam a entrar em trabalho de
parto no mesmo momento a moça grávida
meu deus vou lutar e ea melhoria vou ter
que faz aí estão para aí gritando aquela
dor de pato conseguiu escrever todo o
ano e tem uma vida saindo de mim aí ela
recebe o filho nos braços aí o olhar
muda entendeu é nosso lá senti aquele
amor um filho ea outra tem uma filha
linda coisa mais linda do mundo do nada
o droid que ela deixou entrar
entendendo 4 começa a rasgar as cordas
janela embora a galera veja
olha como é linda com o bebê no braço
começa a ver começa a querer correr pela
janela é a melo e fala me da criança
não eu me da criança ela vai entrega a
criança sai correndo lá morre a mulher
vai tentar impedir morre todo mundo que
tá na frente
morre o cara chega com a arma morte de
menina veneno chip morte ela começa a
treinar as crianças a ouvir bem passar
bem tudo que está acontecendo e ela todo
o tempo no rádio e tv para falar
normalmente
a vibrante alguém por aí até que um dia
alguém responde e fala que tem um lugar
seguro lá no final do rio pega o menino
falou o seguinte nós vamos fazer uma
viagem muito louca em galé a diferença
mas essa que mata ensino da instituição
não tira o carro da fifa entendeu não
tira garoto e garota ela é muito
criativo não domina garoto eo da minha
garota que fica até mais fácil o garoto
podia ter colocado a que o bebê fica
mais fácil a e b pronto aqui e ficar
complicado que toda vez que ele não
visse a letra ele responder é formado
sim eu sou advogado estou na obra foi
diga um artigo na a beleza lá ela pega o
mini saia tudo contadinho que ela tá até
chula é gênio 123 claro pra mim já que
eu sou uma conta rápida com 234 sabendo
que o time erra ao tamanho do passo que
eu medida outra vez estou fazendo maior
ou seja eu ia morrer de fome caminhando
mesmo é embarcar nessa aventura do rio a
equipe é duas horas de duração o filme
vou contar o filme tanto pra você que
assiste quem quiser e se você gostou
desse vídeo não esquece ficarem gostei
que é importante demais como eu falei
toda vez que eu faço a dancinha de
direitos autorais então clique gostei
que você que não inscrito do canal tem
muita gente que não é escrita por que só
me assiste também segue no instagram no
twitter town e quando eu posso assistir
mas não inscrito clicar nesse botão que
inscrever se a gente chegar a 50 milhões
a placa derrube do youtube é nossa o
primeiro brasileiro até ela e eu estou
muito com vontade de que o agente
consiga então se inscreve e clique em
gostei eu queria que você comentasse
aqui embaixo é o maior número 70 do
mundo acabar esse tempo junto aqui está
no instagram meu twitter se você quiser
me seguir é noiva leuer pictures group